mr wonderful kevin o'leary are you there
i'm here great to be here great to see
you as well are you in miami
i am i'm in miami right on the beach
nice do you have pants on no pants
[Laughter]
all right let's talk about uh you you
had a recent trip to uh to the middle
east and uh you talked a bunch about uh
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies regulation
uh infrastructure et cetera tell us a
little bit about the trip why'd you go
and kind of what was the conversation
like with the middle eastern investors
well the largest pension our sovereign
funds in the world are in the middle
east and and i was i really wanted you
know this there's policies that comes
out of the region but then there's also
the opportunity to sit down and talk to
the leadership there about what their
intentions are in specifically bitcoin
mining i was interested to see if there
was a way to invest together
um because
what they're contemplating in some of
these countries are sovereign
mining operations
and so
what what is that going to look like and
so what i learned and this is is you
were talking about institutional
adoptions let me tell you what i think
is going to happen in the next 24 36
months
on this very topic once a sovereign fund
decides it's going to invest in bitcoin
it's going to want to mine it
sustainably and ethically because we've
got a lot of controversy started last
year i remember at bitcoin 2021
and the whole elon musk thing we've
talked about it a lot the conversation
around esg and his is mining bitcoin
going to be compliant with the esg
mandates specifically the larry
fincletter the largest asset manager on
earth blackrock and so
this is what they're this is what i'm
getting out of this conversation and the
way i think i'm going to invest because
i've always wanted to open up my own
mining operations and i'm going to
probably do it in this calendar year so
number one
is it approved by the community it's set
up in both politically and by the people
that live there what's the plan to give
back to that community so let's take a
nordic country sweden or norway or
something like that where a lot of these
adoptions are occurring it's happening
in west texas too but the whole idea is
that you go to that town in west texas
and you you have an agreement with the
mayor and the city council like you're
you're compliant with them to start off
with you're going to give back to the
grant whatever it's going to be you're
going to mine from this from the
the stack heat maybe you do hydroponics
whatever it is you get them on board
number two
can you
keep the
the award if when you get awarded a coin
can you keep it on the balance sheet so
i as an institution
can buy your equity i don't have to buy
the coin i don't have to go to my
committee and say i'm buying bitcoin
anymore i just buy your stock
and now i own the coin as long as you
make the promise to me that you're never
going to sell it because now i know
what's being mined ethically i know
what's being mined with the community in
mind i know the political environment
there's on board i'm not breaching any
regulations and now i own the coin
and i get exposure to the price through
the equity
i tell you guys that's what's going to
happen this year you're going to see a
ton of capital go into these new
projects some of them will use old
chinese stacks because they're all
exiting the country all that equipment
and they're going to be set up in
jurisdictions just like the way i
described it with the equity being the
way the institution owns exposure to
bitcoin pricing and those are the deals
i'm going to invest in so when you think
about that um are there places in the
middle east that you think this will
happen or is it too hot there is the
political climate not ready for like how
do you think of the middle east fitting
into that because you mentioned the
nordic countries you mentioned places
like west texas is the middle east
potentially a place they got a lot of
oil a lot of power production going on
there like how do they think about it
well they also have nuclear power there
too they have excessive electricity
available it's about the cooling you're
right about that there may be a way and
this is being explored by a couple of
ventures right now to build
the facilities way underground in the
underneath the sand like way down so the
cooling becomes far more efficient these
are really really large stacks we're
talking about big
you know close to billion dollar
facilities
i think in this
the way to start thinking about this and
i've come to the conclusion is
different jurisdictions let's let's take
if you're an investor like me you've got
to find jurisdictions where
they're compliant with the local
regulator now the most advanced in my
mind right now
is canada canada was the first to allow
you to do an etf with bitcoin as the
underlying asset then they opened it up
for ethereum now they have multiple etfs
in that jurisdiction that people from
all around the world are investing in
compliant with the regulator
they just license the very first market
crypto exchange the very first in canada
i know that because the company i'm
involved in called wonderfuy bought it
last week for about 160 million dollars
it's the first of its kind this allows
institutions
or individuals right now it's focused on
ethereum and on bitcoin but it's going
to expand the mandate will expand and so
it allows for people to set up accounts
and actually do price discovery on an
exchange so we're very excited about
that so it's got me thinking where else
is this going to happen what other
jurisdictions are going to open this up
and licenses are going to be granted
eastern europe nordic countries middle
east regions so i'm on an airplane all
the time now i'm going to meet with
regulators saying look this is what we
did in canada
can we do this here
and when they say yes i'll invest there
too
i
i want to be
in the exchange business why because i'm
agnostic to price the more volatility
there is the better it is for me so if i
make 8 or 10 or 12 basis points every
time you're trading i'm in a great place
it's the picks and shovels of the the
future of bitcoin and digital currencies
and payment systems i want to be part of
the exchange all right before we talk
about the exchange required one last
question about the uh the mining
if i tweeted and said kevin o'leary is
considering investing in an underground
desert
bitcoin mining facility would that be
like an accurate statement
not yet not yet not yet because the
technology has not been proven got it
it's it's it's being conceptualized but
the reason you don't see a lot of stacks
in middle eastern or desert countries is
what you pointed out at the beginning
pomp the heating costs are brutal yeah i
mean our cooling costs are insanely you
know brutal so that's not it's not time
yet because it hasn't been proven but
each year the technology advances if
there is a cooling system that makes
sense they're going to discover it
because most sovereigns want to mine
bitcoin on their own land
where they have control of it where they
can do it ethically and according to the
regulator's rules most people would want
to do that now west texas and the
governor in texas as you well know has
embraced
crypto specifically bitcoin and there is
a ton of capital going to west texas
right now right down to the town level
and so there's multiple projects there
and i think you're going to see a lot of
capital and there's a big initiative on
right now to find an american
manufacturer for stacks so we don't have
to buy anything in china for obvious
reasons china's got itself a little hot
water here and there as you know but we
don't have that yet so there's a lot to
have happen i think this will be
discussed all through 20 20 22. this is
where the this is where the puck is
going so i've never told you this story
before but i went to kuwait i think it
was in 2018 maybe and uh while i was
there i was at an event uh very well put
together and uh there was a um both
foreigners that were visiting for the
event and also uh kuwaitis and uh one of
them said to me uh hey do you want to
see a kuwait bitcoin mine and i was like
you got a bitcoin mine he's like yeah
and so we went to dinner and then
afterwards we went to this bitcoin mine
and it literally was in a warehouse
basement so like we went to this
warehouse it was kind of you know you're
like all right where are we and then
they brought me down to the basement and
they showed it to me and it wasn't a
huge operation but it was it was big
enough and uh i remember asking him why
are you in the basement he said well you
know one we might not want everyone to
know that we're doing this here but also
too is there's much more uh kind of
cooling capabilities down here so not
quite underground in the desert you know
type thing and not quite the skill
you're talking about uh but you know
years ago there were people who kind of
as an individual or a small business
we're trying to figure this out so it's
cool to kind of see that it's evolved to
the point where now you're talking about
large billion dollar facilities still
trying to conceptualize this and put it
into uh effect now tell me about the
wonderful deal so uh just so everyone
understands this my understanding is
that the canadian regulators went ahead
and they said okay we are going to
actually approve a regulated exchange to
trade in canada uh in the canadian
markets and wonderful and you uh decided
that you were going to be very
opportunistic here and you went ahead
and bought that license so that now you
own the only regulate uh
regulatory approved publicly traded
canadian crypto exchange is that fair
it's not the only one there's two
licenses in canada but this the bit by
one the history of the bit by deal is
wonderful itself had already made a bet
on bit by became an investor in a
private round and so they they already
were exposed to it but it was before the
license was granted there was a lot of
speculation that they would be granted
that license
wasn't done yet but you're taking a
chance and you're betting on it great
management team fantastic guys running
it really knew what they were doing and
it amassed 375 000 accounts because they
were just a dealer broker at that time
like any other but the exchange the
market exchange license was unique and
new and the first of its kind and so we
already knew the management i was really
attracted to the model the whole idea of
having an exchange because if you look
around the world nasdaq new york stock
exchange the london stock exchange the
zurich board all of these places
are where you discover price and as a
result you are the infrastructure
of the liquidity and so i was really
attracted to that idea um that they
would somehow you know get together and
they did and so as an investor i'm just
thrilled i'm very happy about it and now
as you remember the wonderful mandate
was to work in the decentralized
space but what's going on here with bit
by is a centralized exchange with the
accounts so they've combined both and
there's a narrative coming into the
institutional investor think this
through pop
when i talk to institutional investors
about investing in in crypto
infrastructure anywhere
when you acquire a customer i don't care
if you're coinbase if you're wonderfuy
if you're a bit buy you've spent money
to acquire that customer and if you
don't have a full suite of services both
centralized and decentralized there's a
high probability that if they want to go
put their nft on a decentralized wallet
they'll drift out of your sphere and go
do that on their own because you didn't
provide it so these new investments
these new companies that are emerging
are trying to figure out okay if i
acquire a customer how broad a service
base can i create can i be centralized
decentralized can i have brokerage
accounts can i service them in nfts can
i do you know stable coins can i stake
those stable coins for them i'm of the
opinion now as an investor i want
managers that are going to bring a
really broad sweep of service and
products to keep that customer in their
ecosphere this is no different than what
apple thought through decades ago and i
think there's going to be some companies
and i think one or five could be one of
them that emerged with a really large
platter of services
and not just in one geography i've
talked to management there and told them
get on a plane do what i do go meet
other regulators go find out where you
can take this model to other
jurisdictions and i think that's going
to happen because canada is so advanced
a lot of the rules that they've set up
there have worked and i think they're a
great model for other countries and so i
think eastern european countries and
nordic countries are potentially great
places to set up shop
buy exchange licenses bring the
technology over the wonderful has that's
my investment thesis and i've in fact
increased my position there since we
last talked i've invested more
all right and so when you think about
how this is all playing out the last
time we talked you had said that you
were spending more time i think in
partnership with circle if i remember
correctly uh with the stable coin yields
and you're also looking at some of the
decentralized yields that you could
generate walk us through kind of the
yield generation how you're looking at
your portfolio today are you still doing
both centralized and decentralized what
does that look like
right now i'm primarily centralized on
my staking lending and so i'm using two
platforms and soon will be a third uh
with bit buy
ftx is my largest platform obviously i'm
an investor at ftx and a paid
spokesperson i have to disclose that
i do a lot of staking on there pretty
well any asset i'm constantly putting it
out and generating yield there
specifically to usdc though i have
worked with circle circle just updated
their platform with a new treasury
feature the biggest problem we've got i
got to tell you a pop this is still a
nightmare for institutions and it's a
nightmare for me
let's just take staking for a second all
right so i'm regulated i
i'm a regulated entity i have so many
investments in other
standardized financial services
companies and indexing and everything
else so i'm regulated i have an auditor
an external auditor they mark to market
my my internal compliance marks to
market my position every day and every
stock and bond i have it go it's checked
by compliance and then it goes out to
the the statement that the you know the
auditor signs and then we file our paper
i file our our uh compliance reports to
whichever jurisdiction we're in
so think about staking
what a nightmare
you nee you how do you mark to market
that at 405. there's no such thing as a
if the market doesn't stop at four in
the afternoon in crypto world it's just
24 7. so
getting this thing approved just for the
staking because i'm writing contracts
all the time 30 60 90 days whatever it
is
just getting the compliance
guy's head around what we're doing took
six months i've told you this before and
i
and and what we needed was an audit
trail and they and circle just added
that with the treasury tab you can go
back and see every single transaction on
a centralized platform when it happened
when it closed what interest you made so
now the compliance guys are saying oh
this looks like something i'm used to i
get it i'm more comfortable now because
they were treating usdc as an equity as
a stock because we haven't had the
regulator approve i mean this is another
problem right what is usdc it's not an
equity to me
it's a form it's a payment system it's
software but we don't have that ruling
yet and that's what i hope the regulator
does this year is rule on stablecoin
what do you think the ideal uh kind of
framework or sandbox for the stable
coins are do they basically just say
this is a currency and treated like a
currency do you think it's some sort of
regulated asset how do you think of like
the ideal scenario
well
i would like them to rule it i would
what i would this is what i personally
would like this would solve my problem
and i think a lot of other institutions
would agree with this
let's take circle turn it into a bank
fdic
turn it into a bank
and
let my compliance people say oh that's a
currency
it's a currency and it's regulated
currency and it's it's backed up by x
amount of assets just like every other
bank has to comply with the amount of
leverage they put on their balance sheet
and then all of a sudden i wouldn't be
bound by the fact that i have to treat
it like an equity so i can't have more
than five percent of it in a mandate the
typical mandates twenty percent in one
sector five percent any one name very
few institutions you mentioned fairly
earlier any of those funds that they're
managing you're not going to find a
whole lot of the funds that are holding
a position up to 20 in one name they're
kind of maxed out in the five six
percent range
but that when you're dealing with cash
or a currency a swiss franc or or a euro
or a british pound
there's no limits you're basically you
can have 30 in cash 40 in cash 50 in
cash
if we could get stable coins regulated
that way we could now
keep
our liquidity
in in my case i'd like it to be usdc so
that i could be constantly rolling it
because think of the problem i've got i
got cash
inflation seven percent i'm getting 20
basis points on us dollars i'm getting
taxed at six point eight percent right
now there's nothing i can do about it
i'm losing six point eight percent of
value the way to stop that is stake out
my usdc at six and seven percent at
least i'm keeping you know intact with
inflation
but we need the ruling we gotta have
that done and for my compliance people
let me do that because i can't have more
than five percent usd right now they're
treating like a stock
yeah it's incredible to think about how
is the macro economy playing into all of
this in terms of you mentioned inflation
obviously there's a lot of talk right
now about the fed interest rates and
kind of tapering what's your general
thought process on what happens there
with with the fed uh kind of decisions
in 2022.
i think bitcoin and gold are the two
assets that institutions are eyeing for
a hedge against inflation and
so many of the institutions cannot hold
bitcoin so they're exploring owning the
equity of the miners and they run into
the esg problem so
and you know one of the discussions
going on these days about the esg if
you're buying carbon credits to offset
which some are doing some of the big
public miners
who's auditing that book in other words
is there somebody that can show to the
esg committee of an institution that
there really is a true offset the way to
avoid that is what we talked about
earlier simply get a minor that is not
there's zero emissions from the
beginning and that is mining and keeping
the coin on their sheet you just own the
stock i think that's where we're going
but
you know inflation's scary because it's
we did something in this country over
the last 26 months that's never been
done before we basically printed three
trillion dollars i don't care what you
want to call the program you know the
relief program or the ppp or whatever it
was we got out the machine and we
printed three trillion dollars
never been done in any country ever
before never been done here ever before
and then we thought so we don't have to
worry about inflation are you kidding
like look what happened it spiked up to
seven percent in a matter of weeks of
course it's going to do that and now we
have to live with that and the idea of
another three trillion dollars is is is
suicide i mean that's ludicrous we can't
do that okay the buildback better is
dead i mean you can't put that out in
the market now it would it would destroy
the people it's trying to help you'd be
you'd have right now we have on on
protein and meat 24
inflation i mean it's crazy and so
that's gasoline five bucks a gallon in
san diego like that's
people are getting pissed that's what's
happening and they're going to take it
out on the polls
yeah one of the things that uh i don't
have an answer yet to but seems to be
happening is there is a political
appetite obviously for some uh tapering
let's get this inflation down let's you
know do some things to uh to maybe um
have people forget you know how bad the
economic situation is going into uh
election season uh but at the same time
inflation is still seven percent you
know gasoline is up fifty percent food's
up uh you know all these different
things even uh food at home or out of
the home is up six percent each like
this is a really dire situation
according to the official numbers we're
not even talking about the unofficial
numbers uh when you think of that is
there a world where regardless of what
the political will is that the central
banks could be talking about tapering
could be talking about raising rates and
actually back off of that and their
actions aren't as severe as the language
or do you expect them to follow through
with what they're actually saying in
terms of kind of taking a tough stance
against some of this stuff
that's a great question that's why we
have volatility back in the equity
markets because there are some pundits
out there talking about six hikes in a
row and some saying two so somewhere
between those numbers you know is
reality but you've also got this this
this new pandemic whatever you want to
call this this is kind of a different
one than we had 12 months ago but wow
there's a ton of cases i mean it's it's
really uh sweeping through
here in florida we have extraordinary
numbers uh they've shut down the
province of ontario and quebec
virtually shut shut it down because
they've got such a raging endemic going
through there switzerland in the same
boat just talking with my dad over there
i wanted to go and visit them
if they've got over 30 000 cases a day
that's close to what it was at the
height of the original pandemic so
there's issues that i think that you
know the fed is looking at saying i
gotta balance
this against what's really going on and
trying to figure out how fast is this
latest round of pandemic burn itself out
i would like to think by july of this
year
we're through this thing and and the
economy is going to come roaring back
what i find so interesting and this is
probably a great way to look at it
in q4 when analysts started printing and
q4 was almost six percent gdp growth
extraordinary extraordinary gdp growth
but they pulled back assumptions for q1
down to just over three they basically
cut it in half i think this quarter that
we're in right now every index i've got
including private companies i'm invested
in so i see their tear sheets on sales
the economy is on fire it's just booming
i bet you we're gonna print north of
five percent in this quarter
it's going to be much better than people
thought this is my own take on it and
it's going to really boil the equity
markets back up because when you've got
when you talk to 7 inflation you do not
want to be in fixed income you want to
be in something that at least keeps pace
with inflation that's equity so i i
think i think it's going to be a pretty
good quarter but it also may mean that
the fed is hiking but why are they
hiking they're hiking because we've got
such a strong economy and that generally
does not offset the pace forward on
constructive ownership of equities the
first few rate hikes generally do not
destroy a bull market and we are in a
bull market yeah i agree uh my brothers
have questions here in a second but uh
the other question i want to ask you is
i see you go on cnbc a few times and uh
getting some uh verbal tussles you know
back in the day you and i used to have
some verbal tussles which i just want to
remind people of but uh recently you've
been asked about the vaccine mandates
and kind of choice versus mandates etc
like what's your general take
now that we're in kind of as you said
like a new version of this whole thing
and like how do you think business
owners specifically should be thinking
about this obviously with shark tank
there's a lot of small business owners
that watch and they like the show etc
when you talk to those business owners
like how are they balancing the health
stuff versus running their businesses
supply chain it's just a very complex
environment right now so like how do you
think about that how do you talk to
those companies
so i have been talking to those
companies because i've wanted to get
some tonality of their policy and start
applying it to ours in the case where
we're controlled shareholder i want to
respect people's rights to do what they
wish with their own personal health at
the same time i want to respect the
employees that work together and so
the way i think it should shake out on
private business you know this just got
tested in the supreme court and got
rejected
it the government shouldn't be able to
do a mandate to a private company and
tell them what to do the private company
should be able to decide their own
policy and indeed that's what's
happening there are many companies that
have made the decision at the board
level that if you're going to work
together in an office in an airplane in
a factory in a manufacturing facility
whatever
you have to be vaccinated now you don't
have to be vaccinated but you're not
going to have a job so you're going to
have to make that decision individually
and some people are going to make the
decision they're not going to get
vaccine they're going to go find try and
find a job where they can work remotely
in perpetuity or they you know a company
that doesn't have a policy like that but
if you go down the s p 500 slowly but
surely since we last talked pomp you've
seen many large entities put in place
including citibank recently that edict
giving people time to get their vaccines
paying for the vaccines giving them time
off to go get their vaccines supporting
them any way they can but if they don't
choose to get vaccinated
they lose their job and i'm okay with
that i'm okay with it it still gives you
the personal right to do what you wish
but it shows respect to your fellow
worker that you don't want to infect
them because really we're all in this
thing together it's been said countless
times and we are
but you know if you want if you want to
get sick right now you just go into a
room with 20 people somebody's going to
have covet and you're going to get sick
and if you're vaccinated you're going to
survive if you're not the outcome is
unknown
joe john what questions you guys got i'm
gonna pull us a little bit closer back
to the middle of uh of discussing
digital assets
kevin they don't like that i like
talking about you know important topics
they like to talk about
i'm just saying he's here for a reason
we're gonna let him uh we're gonna bring
him right back in go ahead um
let's talk about some of the investments
you're making i know that you've been
public about kind of the the specific
assets that you're investing in and it's
pretty diversified portfolio you've got
bitcoin ethereum solana polygon and
others
i want to talk about just quickly if you
can run through your general framework
of how you determine where you're going
to allocate capital
so
i have come to the conclusion on all all
things digital the best way to look at
it and i've said this several times
bitcoin is not a coin it's software
ethereum is not
a blockchain it's software it's all
software hbar software
and and so what i do is i say to myself
i've seen this movie before i was an
investor in software you know engineers
22 years ago at the learning company
when we made educational software
so the way i used to do it then is the
way i'm doing it now i'm very lucky guy
i can make a phone call and it always
gets returned that's the whole shark
tank thing and i get all that but if i
want to invest in polygon i want to meet
the engineering team which i did in
dubai i called him up met him at the
team
heard their vision of what they're doing
looked at the economic reality of the
outcome the potential of it so
first is team i want to meet the team
if i if i check the box on team smart
guys good engineers good strategy good
group i'm interested here's the test the
second test
what economic value are they creating in
the case of polygon let's stay on that
polygon for a second aggregating
transactions to reduce gas fees on each
is a smart idea there's a reason you
would do that because you have an
economic reason to pursue that you save
money transaction fees are less so i
think the potential of that is large
h bar okay great team good engineers
what's the economic premise that would
keep that
growing well boeing wants a
quasi-centralized decentralized platform
they want the best of both worlds hbar
can deliver that check the box there buy
into that one too
look what's going on with you know
solana
i mean they're trying to solve problems
a different way too speed everything up
check the box who's working on that sam
bank and freedom his team why wouldn't
you bet that horse so it's all about
getting positions in all of these
you know
software platforms that's what they are
they're software platforms so i i stay
in institutions you you criticize me for
investing in bitcoin you own a big
position at microsoft do you own a five
percent waiting in yahoo what is that
that's software why don't you do the
same thing in bitcoin why don't you do
the same thing in ethereum why aren't
you an hbo why aren't you polygon why
aren't you in serum why aren't you in
helium like it's all software
and so with with that attitude on it's
hard to say i'll only invest in publicly
traded software companies one day these
to me and i really believe this one day
crypto and all these software platforms
are going to be the 12th sector of the s
p and i'm just taking the bet now that
we're on our way there and i'm taking
and staking my bets now
broad portfolio you know no one ethereum
is my biggest position right now
bitcoin's had a bit of a correction i
get it but there's been volatility but
now
to offset that volatility i own an
exchange
so i want to own more exchanges
i look at it it's all software
john kevin yeah thanks for coming on you
talk about
um this industry being the 12th sector
of the s p and recently drone powell
said that their report on crypto and
cbdc's are coming is coming out soon
what are your thoughts on the impact
that that report can have and what do
you think that report will contain
i'm encouraged by that report because it
shows that they're inching forward and
they're trying to do it right i my
opinion about the regulator is they're
they understand the tremendous potential
of this technology the potential of you
know streamlined payment systems the
potential of productivity
that
blockchain has in smart contracts and
all the use the case uses for it they
get it
but at the same time they're well aware
that when they rule it will be the
global standard the chinese aren't going
to do this no one's going to follow them
they're going to follow the sec they're
going to follow the us regulator so they
want to get it right
the first place i would like them to get
it right would be on the baseline
stablecoin as a payment system i would
very very much like to be able to
transact globally
pick a coin my preference is usdc but
pick one
regulate it and let me as a investor
along with hundreds of millions of other
investors
use it as a form of payment and
stability
it would be fantastic if it was backed
by the us dollar they know that they
know that
it would be just be so much more
efficient and so
you know so less expensive if i could
just transact maintain a centralized
centralized wallet
um and just be able to imagine if i
could buy a swiss stock with a stable
coin instead of having to go us dollar
into swiss franc
buy the security then back into swiss
franc back in the us dollar you know how
screwed i get doing that how much
friction there is and how much i lose
it's insane same with euro stocks same
with british pounds same with canadian
dollars i mean i invest in all these
jurisdictions and i have to deal with
that
and so it's sort of that's where i think
we want to go first once they rule on
that everybody will say okay we're
moving in that direction it'll be very
constructive for the asset allocation
you talked about at the beginning of the
hour on institutional follow-through
into crypto there's no question you're
right there's a lot of demand they just
need the regulator on board
kevin what's interesting about that idea
is basically the us dollar if it does
get uh kind of the blessing right i
think a lot about like the uh the
regulators are essentially the pope at
this point right they're just going to
give the blessing to the stable coins
especially things like usdc etc uh when
that happens there's not a lot of reason
for people to go back into the
antiquated technologies of the same
currency so we just have physical
dollars now we have what's called an
electronic dollar which is in a
centralized database with uh kind of uh
long settlement times to eventually just
move to the digital version and so
monetary policy doesn't change just a
new technology upgrade uh if that was to
happen do you think that the other
currencies around the world would suffer
and what i mean by that is if you have
us dollars rather than be forced to go
into swiss francs before you go and buy
a stock now you're just going to go
straight from usdc into the stock do
some of these weaker currencies um and
maybe not in developed nations
especially in like developing countries
they start to suffer at the hands
of the more dominant fiat currencies or
how do you think about that
yeah the way i look at it is there's
going to be
um
four or five currencies that will be
digitized so there will be a digital
version of the swiss franc there will be
a digital version of the euro there will
be a digital version of the british
pound there'll be a digital version of
the canadian dollar
there'll be a digital version of the us
dollar it may be a stable coin in that
case but the reason i think that happens
is you allow the economies to compete
with each other on productivity and
interest rates so that if i'm going to
go buy something in switzerland there'll
be a spot exchange price from my usdc or
whatever the stablecoin is into the
stable version of the swiss franc and i
may elect to keep a portfolio
as i do today of multiple currencies
because basically i want to own swiss
francs that country is very very
efficient it's a very good currency they
don't have a lot of debt so how do i own
the digital version of that because
right now if you want to own native
swiss francs
you practically can't do it because if
you want to open an account in
switzerland as an american citizen you
can't you can't do it they won't open it
for you
i think all of this political um
border stuff goes away
with digitization of the currency so i'm
very optimistic for that now the reason
you only have four or five of them
chinese one yeah that's going to be
digital at some point but i own a
chinese lawn probably not if the
government's watching
you know my wallet address and it'll be
an unfavored currency for that reason
but i've happily owned swiss francs
happily owned the digital american
dollar
it'll it's going to play itself out but
you said you're saying you know
if it happens
100 is going to happen it's just when
the efficiency just if we just digitize
our dollar or we got a stable dollar
like a bank if circle became a bank i
don't need anything else
i'll just
own that and i'll piece it off
digitally whenever i need to buy some
some other kind of asset
and i'll be staking it at whatever the
current rate is i'll be rolling my
contracts and just like in the old days
when you could make five six percent
interest which you don't get anymore and
so i think there's a really big use case
and why there's so much pressure on the
regulator to rule on this thing and you
guys are dead right the efficiency
brought forward is just insane it's so
powerful an economic reason to pursue
this
agreed last question then we'll let you
get back to uh miami beach you know get
a little tan going because it's 70
something degrees here for anyone who's
stuck in new york at 12 degree weather
uh is um when you think about your
portfolio i think previously you were
kind of
two three four percent you had
aspirations but not quite at i think it
was like eight percent nine percent
somewhere in that range is what you were
kind of targeting and eventually you
said that you could see going up to like
20
in uh in a single sector uh but that
would take some time to get there where
are you today and how have your thoughts
around uh kind of portfolio allocation
percentages how has that changed the
last time we talked
yeah
so um
at year end last year we thought we'd be
at seven where we were at 10
0.7
in the operating company portfolio and
today i just this morning i got off with
our our compliance guys um because of
our recent investments uh additional
investments in some of the equities that
we bought
um i increased my position
in hold immutable holdings the jordan
freed company that owns nft.com
uh i bought more of that and i also
bought a lot more of on the deal of uh
the wonder if i did buying blockchain or
by bit buy
we're now
today
at um
16.5
and so we're on our way to 20 and it
happened really really fast um
and i'm comfortable with it it's more
volatile than our traditional book
because when you look at what else we
own it's you know commercial real estate
it's large cap uh s p cu companies
dividend payers a lot of them
this stuff is volatile but the
underlying potential and the growth of
it
um and i i know that a lot of
institutions are going through the the
angst i'm having
i can't find better opportunities than
these companies like they are
really this is like investing in the
earliest days
of the internet the earliest days
because we're in the first inning of
this stuff and so you you got you have
to find your opportunities where they
are and and
you know
probably by the end of this quarter i'm
going to be at 20 but that's what's
happening here
so
i think i said this to you before uh on
the show but if not
in 2018
you forbid me it was garbage the whole
night
i knew before the day was over you're
gonna bring that up again hold on hold
on this is a compliment though but
from there to essentially let's call it
three years later or less so within
three years
from that perspective which actually i
will uh admit was a fair perspective for
most people to have at the time because
they had just watched bitcoin go from
twenty thousand fall to three uh
thousand dollars
to now have 16
of your portfolio in the industry and
not only have what i'll call like true
skin in the game and in a growing
percentage but to be able to talk about
it with such detailed nuance the
understanding of the regulatory side the
technology etc
i got to say kudos man i'm very
impressed i think that you not only
understand what's happening here but uh
you're kind of not sitting back letting
it you know
like pass by you you're jumping into it
and i think there's a lot of people who
you would consider your peers that they
may say okay yeah he's probably not
wrong but like let's figure out what to
do let's go read some white papers
whatever and they're gonna take another
two years before they jump in and
they're just gonna miss a huge piece of
this so it's not only the the
willingness to change your mind and all
that but it's also the the courage and
conviction to kind of act in a way that
16 like that's not going to sneeze your
nose at especially because you have
these like weird rules like no more than
twenty percent uh uh single sector no
more than five percent in the single
stock it's you know it's like almost
like i know all your talking points on
that stuff
yeah no you're right but that is the way
the mandates work out there globally and
sovereign and figuring everything out
you know it's sort of um
one of the challenges i've got is i have
to include uh
my my holdings and my contracts on usdc
as basically an equity as i said earlier
which to me is frustrating um because
i would i would you know i can't get
past 20 but it should be treated like
what it is it's a it's a currency where
there are no rules like that but we're
not there yet and it's it's a push i i
will say one thing in closing watch what
happens this year in the amount of
capital that comes into that new mining
model
that
we're going to solve this esg problem in
2022 you're going to see
a lot of institutional capital come into
this idea of mining within a community
supporting a community doing an esg
compliant ethically compliant all that
stuff and they'll own the equity just
like they own any other equity but
they'll be exposed to the vol
of bitcoin that's how they're going to
do it
yeah i think that uh i i think that
people are underestimating how uh
violently institutional capital moves
when it moves uh we saw this with
bitcoin in um 2020 into 2021 uh there
was really a lot of the price was driven
by uh the arbitrage for the grayscale
bitcoin trust i mean there was just
massive capital inflows there uh and
because that capital couldn't be
redeemed uh there ended up being this
huge price increase at one point i think
grayscale was buying like 150 percent of
all bitcoin being mined every day right
so it was just they were just sucking
liquidity out of the market and that was
just institutional capital and it
frankly wasn't the big boys it was hedge
funds and family offices etc
i do think that once the really really
large firms whether it's the sovereign
wealth the you know large trillion
dollar asset managers et cetera when
they start to allocate you know i mean
if you really think about it right now
if a trillion dollar asset manager said
we're gonna go put 100 allocation of
bitcoin
they could buy from a price concept all
the bitcoin that is liquid traded on the
market now of course they can't actually
get someone's gonna sell it to them but
like they have enough money to buy the
entire market cap and so i think people
just they don't understand how much
money these people have and how quickly
i agree with your analysis of what
happened there that was not healthy for
the market i prefer more transparency
more liquidity and i think we're going
to get it through you know massive
amounts of
of capital going into the equity of
minors that's the way it's going to
first manifest itself and that'll have
much more liquidity much more
transparency much more disclosure and
it'll be compliant it's i think it's a
trade of 2022 i think you're going to
see a bunch of deals announced a lot of
them in west texas i'm aware of a lot of
these deals and certainly looking at
them and i'm planning on investing in
some of them so i can make claim to
owning direct esg compliant coin and
that's what every other institution
wants to do anyways listen i've really
enjoyed it
another great session let's do it again
soon
all right i appreciate you very much
where do you want us to send people
you know cut follow me on social it's
kevin o'leary tv on any platform i i do
i talk a lot about our projects on
instagram twitter linkedin um
you know facebook
it's it's a communication with you know
my followers that and i love to hear
their opinions about this stuff people
are getting very interested in this
asset class at every
group it's the future of our economy
it's
age
that's how you started this whole show
you're right that's what it is it's true
the official channel of kevin o'leary
dropping cold hard truths
[Laughter]
that's amazing all right thank you so
much i appreciate it we'll do it again
soon take care bye-bye bye